Well,
now really when we go back then to
falling in love and say it's crazy
falling.
See,
we don't say rising into love,
isn't it?
The idea of the fall and uh,
it is,
goes back.
As a matter of fact,
two extremely fundamental things that,
that is always a curious it at some
point between the fall and the creation.
Taking this gosling risk is the
condition of that being live you see for
all life is an act of faith and an act
of gamble.
The moment you take a step,
you will do so on an act of faith
because you don't really know that the
flaw is not going to give unto your feet
the limits.
You take a journey.
What an act of faith.
The moment you enter into any kind of
Hulan undertaking in relationship,
what an act of faith.
See you've given yourself up.
But this is the most powerful thing that
can be done.
Surrender.
See I love is an act of surrender to
another person.
Total abandonment.
I give myself to you,
take me through anything you like when
you see so that's quite mad because you
see it's letting things get out of
control.
All sensible people keep things in
Watch it,
watch it,
watch it.
Security vigilance,
watching police watch it.
God's watching who's going to watch the
gods?
So actually,
therefore the,
the,
the cost of wisdom.
What is really a sensible,
uh,
is to let go,
is to commit oneself,
to give oneself up.
And that's quite mad.
So we come to the strange conclusion
that in madness lies sanity.